ANNOUNCER 1: The following
content is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
mitopencourseware@ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today we're going to study
something called the
hyperbolic functions.
And in a sense, we're going to
show that in a very major way,
the study of the hyperbolic
functions mimics the study of
the circular functions.
And so in a sense, what we will
do is parrot much of what
we did for circular functions
to wind up with
our hyperbolic functions.
Since the basic difference
between a hyperbola and a
circle is a sign, namely 'x
squared' plus 'y squared'
equals 1 versus, say, 'x
squared' minus 'y squared'
equals 1, I've entitled today's
lesson, 'What a
difference a sign makes'.
Now, by way of brief review,
recall that the circular
functions originated as follows:
we said consider the
circle whose equation is
'x squared' plus 'y
squared' equals 1.
That's a circle over here.
Then what we did was picking
this as a starting point, and
taking any length, 't', we wrap
't' around the circle.
When the length, 't', terminated
at point, 'p', we
defined what?
Cosine 't' to equal 'x' and
sine 't' to equal 'y'.
That was basically the geometric
interpretation of
the circular functions, after
which we showed that there was
a physical meaning
to this as well.
Now you see what we'd like to
do is the same thing only
which regard now to
what I would call
the hyperbolic functions.
And you may recall that in our
lecture on circular functions,
I mentioned the hyperbola
very briefly.
Now I'd like to go back to the
hyperbola in somewhat more
detail, namely we now look at
the equation 'x squared' minus
'y squared' equals 1.
See just to change of
sign over here.
The graph of 'x squared'
minus 'y squared'
equals 1 is the hyperbola.
And by the way, notice already
one significant change when we
change the sign here.
Notice that in the case of 'x
squared' plus 'y squared'
equals 1, our curve essentially
came in one piece.
Now you see our curve has
two different branches.
And for the sake of uniformity,
for the sake of
well-definedness, let's pick the
branch that we will deal
with to be the positive branch,
meaning the branch
that's to the right
of the y-axis.
To mimic precisely what we did
in the case of the circular
functions, what we
do now is what?
Given any length, 't', we start
at 's', mark 't' off
along the upper branch
of this double-valued
curve if 't' is positive.
Mark it off along the lower
branch if 't' is negative.
Wherever 't' terminates,
we call that point 'p'.
And then to complete our analogy
with the circular
functions, we define the
x-coordinate of 'p' to be the
hyperbolic cosine written
C-O-S-H and pronounced cosh.
'Cosh t' is 'x'.
And the hyperbolic sine is
the y-coordinate of 'p'.
And that's written S-I-N with
an h, hyperbolic sine
pronounced cinch.
In other words, 'cosh t' is
the x-coordinate of 'p'.
'Sinh t' is the y-coordinate
of 'p'.
And the same way that 'x
squared' plus 'y squared'
equals 1 gave us the circular
identity that 'sine squared t'
plus 'cosine squared t' is 1,
the fact that 'x squared'
minus 'y squared' is 1 gives
us the hyperbolic identity
that 'cosh squared t' minus
'sinh squared t' is 1.
So again, notice great
similarities, great
differences.
I'd like to make just a brief
aside to point out how in one
sense this difference isn't
too significant.
Yet in another sense, it's
very significant.
Notice the following: if you
look at the equation, 'x
squared' minus 'y squared'
equals 1, and if I can draw on
your previous knowledge of the
square root of minus 1 just
for a moment for sake
of illustration.
If we think of 'i' as being a
number whose square is minus
1, noticed another way of
writing 'x squared' minus 'y
squared' is to write
'x squared' plus
the number 'iy squared'.
You see 'i squared' is minus 1.
'y squared' is 'y squared'.
This is just another way of
saying 'x squared' minus 'y
squared' is 1.
Again, it's not that crucial.
But because much later in the
course when we study complex
numbers, there is going to be
a rather nice identification
between hyperbolic functions
and circular functions as a
prelude of things to come.
Notice that what we're saying
is if you plot 'x squared'
minus 'y squared' equals 1, if
you plot that in the xy-
plane, you get the hyperbola
that we talked about.
On the other hand, if you change
the name of the y-axis
to the iy-axis, notice that with
respect to this type of
coordinate system, the graph
would be a circle.
Again, just an aside to show you
structurally a connection
between circles and hyperbolas
in terms of complex numbers.
In that way, these things
out fairly similar.
Now to show you how different
a sign change is, I thought
you might be interested in the
following little device.
Take any two numbers, 'a' and
'b', no matter how different,
and form two numbers, one
of which is half the
sum of 'a' and 'b'.
And the other is half the
difference of 'a' and 'b'.
It's a trivial verification to
show that the sum of 'x' and
'y' is 'a'.
And the difference
'x - y' is 'b'.
In other words, no matter how
different 'a' and 'b' are, we
can always find two numbers, 'x'
and 'y', such that just by
changing the sign, namely if we
add the pair of numbers, we
get one of the numbers.
If we subtract them,
we get the other.
Just to make this a little bit
more vivid, suppose, for
example, 'a' happens
to be 1,000.
And suppose 'b' happens
to be 4.
Now there's no danger of
confusing these two numbers.
They're quite different.
On the other hand, notice that
half the sum is 502, and half
the difference is 498.
You see if I add these two
numbers I get 1,000.
If I subtract them I get 4.
And therefore, notice that
just by changing the sign
here, I can effectively create
a change from 4 to 1,000.
I just mentioned that to show
why these people who say
things like, all I was, was off
by a sign, that making a
sign mistake is very, very
crucial, especially if the
answer later on has to be added
on to something else.
But any rate, I didn't even
have to give this example.
Except that I thought
it was a cute little
aside for you to notice.
From a more practical point of
view, if we just go back to
these two graphs that we've
drawn, notice that just
changing the plus sign to a
minus sign radically changed
the shape of the curve that
we were talking about.
So at any rate then,
this gives us
the hyperbolic functions.
And a very natural question to
raise at this time, is why the
hyperbolic functions now?
Why study them now?
Why didn't we do it before?
Why did we wait until
we were dealing
with exponential functions?
The answer is that the
exponential functions give us
a very vivid way of
reconstructing
the hyperbolic functions.
And the key lies in the
following fact.
It lies in the fact that the
derivative of 'e' to the 'u'
with respect to 'x' is 'e'
to the 'u' times 'du/dx'.
In particular, if I take the
derivative of 'e' to the 't'
with respect to 't', I
get 'e' to the 't'.
If I take the derivative of
'e' to the minus 't' with
respect to 't', I get what?
'e' to the minus 't' times the
derivative of minus 't' with
respect to 't'.
That's minus 1.
So the derivative of 'e' to the
minus 't' is minus 'e' to
the minus 't'.
Well what does this have
to do with anything?
Notice that if I now construct a
new function, 'e' to the 't'
plus 'e' to the minus 't', since
the derivative of a sum
is the sum of derivatives,
notice that this result here
tells me that the derivative of
'e' to the 't' plus 'e' to
the minus 't' with respect to
't' is 'e' to the 't' minus
'e' to the minus 't'.
Now let me do this operation
once again.
Suppose I now take 'e' to the
't' minus 'e' to the minus 't'
and I differentiate that
with respect to 't'.
Well, the derivative 'e'
to the 't' gives me
'e' to the 't' again.
The derivative of 'e' to the
minus 't' is minus 'e'
to the minus 't'.
Minus times minus is plus.
So observe that if I
differentiate 'e' to the 't'
minus 'e' to the minus 't', I
come back to 'e' to the 't'
plus 'e' to the minus 't'.
Notice already how this starts
to behave, at least a little
bit, like our friends sine and
cosine, except again, for a
little change in sign, namely if
I give this function here a
special name.
And to make it suggestive, I'm
going to call it 'c of t'.
'c' sort of to indicate
cosine.
But I don't want
to write cosine
because it's not a cosine.
Let me just call this function
here 'c of t' and its
companion, as you may guess,
I will call 's of t'.
'c of t' is 'e' to the 't' plus
'e' to the minus 't'.
's of t' is 'e' to the 't' minus
This pair of functions has
the property that what?
The derivative of one of them is
always the other, which is
not quite what sine
and cosine did.
Remember if you differentiated
the sine, you got the cosine.
But if you differentiated
the cosine, you
didn't get the sine.
You got minus the sine.
So you see, again, a similarity,
but not exactly
the same thing.
Nonetheless we get a little
bit suspicious about this.
We see that the derivative of
'c' is 's', the derivative of
's' is 'c'.
We remember that there was a
basic identity involving sine
squared plus cosine squared.
We might get the premonition
that maybe there's some
relationship between 's squared'
and 'c squared'.
And one of the best ways of
checking out a premonition is
to just check it out.
I mean let's just see
what happens.
In other words, starting with
this definition of 'c'--
this is a binomial--
let's square it.
You see if we square
it, it's what?
It's 'e' to the '2t', the first
term squared, plus twice
the product of these
two terms.
But 'e' to the 't' times 'e' to
the minus 't' is 'e' to the
0, which is 1, plus 'e' to the
minus 't squared', which is
'e' to the minus '2t'.
In other words, putting this
all together, the square of
'c' is 'e' to the '2t' plus
twice 1, which is 2, plus 'e'
to the minus '2t'.
Similarly, when we square 's',
we get exactly the same thing
only with a minus 2
as the middle term
rather than a plus 2.
Well now we look at 'c squared'
and 's squared'.
And just by looking at this
expression, any hope that 'c
squared' plus 's squared'
will give us a nice
identity should vanish.
Because you see, if you add
these, you're going to get an
'e' to the '2t' term
in here, in fact,
twice 'e' to the '2t'.
Here you'll get twice 'e'
to the minus '2t'.
And only the 2 and the minus
2 will drop out.
On the other hand, should you
elect to subtract 's squared'
from 'c squared', the 'e' to the
'2t' terms cancel, the 'e'
to the minus '2t' term
cancels, and we
wind up with what?
'c squared' minus 's squared'
is identically 4.
And by the way, notice
up to this point, no
use of the word hyperbola.
OK?
However, if you think of the
so-called unit hyperbola, the
one for which 'x squared' minus
'y squared' is 1, notice
that 'c squared' minus
's squared' equals 4
almost has that form.
Well it has the form.
All that's spoiling it
is the 4 on the side.
Now you could pretend
the 4 was a 1.
But that would be cheating.
What we do instead is just
divide both sides of this
equation by 4, observing that
'c squared t' over 4 is just
'c of t' over 2 squared.
's squared t' over 4 is just
's of t' over 2 squared.
In other words, dividing through
by 4, this equation
can be put into this form.
And now you see we satisfy the
basic hyperbolic identity of
this squared minus this
squared equals 1.
By the way, since the c's and
the s's may not seem familiar
to us, what we can do is what?
Go back to the basic
definition.
'c of t' meant 'e' to the 't'
plus 'e' to the minus 't'.
Therefore, half of 'c of t' is
'e' to the 't' plus 'e' to the
minus 't' over 2.
's of t' was 'e' to the 't'
minus 'e' to the minus 't'.
Therefore 's of t' over 2 is
'e' to the 't' minus 'e' to
the minus 't' over 2.
And again, the reason I bring
this out, is it in most
textbooks they simply define
the hyperbolic
functions this way.
I find it a poor motivation.
I don't find it easy to motivate
where are the clear
blue sky, you bring in a
2 in the denominator.
All I want you to see in terms
of motivating what's going on
so far, is that if I just
defined a function to be 'e of
t' plus 'e' to the minus 't' and
another one to be 'e of t'
minus 'e' to the minus 't', I
could have shown that the
first squared minus the
second squared was 4.
And the motivation of putting
the 2 in the denominator is
for no greater reason than to
help us satisfy the equation
'x squared' minus 'y
squared' equals 1.
In fact, this is now the
connection between what we
were doing a few months ago
and what we're doing now.
Namely if I now call this 'cosh
t' and I call this 'sinh
t', do I get my basic
hyperbola?
Namely, suppose I take a curve
whose equation is given
parametrically by 'x' equal
'cosh t' and 'y' equal 'sinh
t', where cosh and sinh are
now defined as over here
without any reference to the
hyperbola, in the same way
that we could define the
circular functions in terms of
calculus without having to
appeal to the circle.
What I'm saying is, suppose we
had never mentioned the word
hyperbolic function up to now.
We've developed a function
called 'cosh t', a function
called 'sinh t' just from these
two relationships here.
If I eliminate the parameter 't'
here, namely if I square
both sides of each equation
and subtract, I get 'x
squared' minus 'y squared' is
'cosh squared t' minus 'sinh
squared t'.
But that I already say is 1.
In other words, this
parametrically gives us the
hyperbola 'x squared' minus
'y squared' equals 1.
By the way, let's make
another observation.
Notice that the exponential
could never be negative.
See 'e' to the minus 't' is 1
over 'e' to the 't', which is
still positive.
Notice that the cosh can
never be negative.
See, 'e' to the 't' is
a positive number.
'e' to the minus 't' is
Therefore, notice that in this
particular relationship, not
only is the curve given by 'x
squared' minus 'y squared'
equals 1, but since the cosh
can never be negative, it's
also characterized by
'x' is positive.
And you see that
tells us what?
That what we're getting this
way is not the entire
hyperbola, but just the branch
for which 'x' is positive,
which is exactly what we
were talking about
earlier in the lesson.
Again, I leave further details
of this to the exercises.
All I want to do in today's
lesson is to get the flavor of
what's going on, how we can
invent the hyperbolic
functions without reference
to a hyperbola
until we're all done.
See, I hope you see this
juxtaposition.
We've done two things here.
One is we've started with the
hyperbola and showed how we
could invent this
construction.
The other is we started with the
exponential and showed how
we could construct two functions
of the exponential
which had the property that they
could be identified with
the thing that was called the
hyperbolic cosine and
hyperbolic sine.
In other words, we could take
either of the two approaches
and derive the other.
But I don't want to put in all
of those details here.
OK?
At any rate, to show you where
calculus comes in, in terms of
what I meant by saying that
as far as this course is
concerned, we have now finished
the groundwork both
with respect to differential
and integral calculus.
Suppose, for example,
I now want to define
the hyperbolic tangent.
See y equals hyperbolic
tangent 'x'.
How could I do that?
Well, I mimic the circular
function definition.
I say, OK, I will define the
hyperbolic tangent to be the
hyperbolic sine over the
hyperbolic cosine.
By the way, in the same way that
one can show in terms of
geometric constructions on the
unit circle how one constructs
the tangent and the cotangent
and the cosecant and the
secant, et cetera, once sine
and cosine and given.
It can also be shown that we can
construct these things in
terms of geometry from
the hyperbola.
But because that gets
computationally involved, I've
also saved those aspects
for the exercises.
I'm not going to worry about
how you construct the
hyperbolic tangent given the
hyperbolic sine and the
hyperbolic cosine right now.
All I'm saying is suppose
you've made up this
definition.
And now if somebody says gee,
I would like to find the
derivative of the hyperbolic
tangent of 'x'.
What I want to point out is that
the recipes that we need
are no different from anything
we've had before.
Namely, since the hyperbolic
tangent of 'x' is 'sinh x'
over 'cosh x', I use
the same quotient
rule as I used before.
Namely, to differentiate the
hyperbolic tangent, I
differentiate this quotient.
How do we differentiate
a quotient?
It's the denominator times the
derivative of the numerator.
Well the numerator
is 'sinh x'.
The derivative 'sinh
x' is 'cosh x'.
That gives me a 'cosh squared
x' over here minus the
numerator, which is 'sinh x'
times the derivative of the
denominator.
Well the derivative of 'cosh
x' is 'sinh x'--
that give me another factor--
over the square of
the denominator.
Now my basic identity is that
cosh squared minus sinh
squared is 1.
So this is just 1 over
'cosh squared x'.
And if I want to write this
all on one line, I could
invent the notation that the
hyperbolic secant is 1 over
the hyperbolic cosine.
In other words, I could invent
a notation like this.
But again, the important point
is not so much what this
answer is, but how I can
derive it from first
principles.
And by the way, in terms of the
inverse derivative, once I
know that the derivative of
hyperbolic tangent is a square
of the hyperbolic secant, I can
immediately add to my list
of inverse derivatives.
Namely I just have
to write it down.
See there's an integral formula
that I now have.
But again, all I want to
emphasize here is how the
details take care of themselves
in the same way as
always once we have our
basic definitions.
It might be interesting just
in terms of cementing down
what sinh and cosh look like,
in the same way that we have
talked about sine and cosine,
it might be nice to
graph sinh and cosh.
And again notice, in terms of
curve plotting, how do we plot
'y' equals 'f of x'?
The general procedure
was what?
Always take the first and second
derivatives so that you
can see what the slope
is, what the
concavity is, et cetera.
The derivative of
cosh is sinh.
sinh is cosh.
By the way, again, if these
terms seem alien to you, you
can always rewrite them in terms
of the basic definition,
in terms of 'e' to the 'x' and
'e' to the minus 'x', and
carry out the differentiation
in a straightforward way.
Well here's the interesting
point.
Let's plot 'y' equals
'cosh x'.
Notice first of all that 'cosh
x' is an even function.
If I replace 'x' by minus 'x',
all I get is what? 'e' to the
minus 'x' plus 'e' to the 'x'
over 2, which is the same
thing as I have over here.
It's going to be a symmetric
function with a curve with
respect to the y-axis.
But again, what do I do?
I compute the derivative.
I can find out where the
derivative is 0.
It's 0 when 'e' to the 'x'
equals 'e' to the minus 'x'.
That happens only
when 'x' is 0.
When 'x' is 0, this is 'e' to
the 0 plus 'e' to the 0.
That's 1 plus 1, which is
2 over 2, which is one.
So in other words, the
derivative is 0 when 'x' is 0
and 'y' is 1.
The second derivative is cosh.
We've already seen that this
can never be negative.
So the second derivative
is always positive.
That means that the curve
is always holding water.
Putting all this together, the
curve 'y' equals 'cosh x'
looks something like this.
It's a dangerous thing
to say it sort
of resembles a parabola.
It's nothing like a parabola
except what I mean is it has
this type of shape.
Notice it does not oscillate.
It is not an oscillating
function like the cosine.
It doesn't act periodically.
This thing just keeps
going like this.
All right?
On the other hand, how can we
plot 'y' equals 'sinh x'?
Well, I guess we come
right back to here
and work from here.
The derivative of
sinh is cosh.
But cosh is always at least
as big as 1 we found out.
Therefore, the slope of
'sinh x' is always at
least as big as 1.
And it's equal to
1 when 'x' is 0.
Putting all these details
together,
what we find is what?
First of all, the sinh is an odd
function, meaning that if
we replace 'x' by minus 'x',
we change the sign.
So this is 'e to the minus x'
minus 'e to the x', which is a
negative of what we
have over here.
But those, again, are details
which are easy
for you to fill in.
The graph 'y' equals 'sinh x'
looks something like this.
In other words, it's
a very steep curve.
It's spilling water and
rising here, holding
water and rising here.
The curve is always rising.
Again, another interesting thing
to observe here is that
notice that when 'x' is very,
very large, 'e' to the minus
'x' becomes negligible.
And if 'e' to the minus 'x' is
negligible, notice that both
sinh and cosh behave like
1/2 'e to the x'.
In other words, this term
tends to drop out.
And just to show you the
contrast here, I've sketched
in the curve 'y' equals '1/2 'e
to the x'' to show you how
it splits the difference for
large values of 'x' between
these two in a way.
And as 'x' gets larger, both
of these curves converge on
'y' equals '1/2 'e to the x''.
Again, I simply want to mention
enough here so that
you get the idea of how we can
apply the same old calculus to
our new function.
What I'd like to do in closing
is to try again from our point
of view of being engineeringly
oriented to show why the
hyperbolic functions might have
occurred in nature, in
the same way that we tried
to show that the circular
functions had a natural
outgrowth in terms of nature.
You recall that the circular
functions were motivated in
terms of simple harmonic
motion.
The circular functions would
have been invented when we
talked about motion, in which
the acceleration was
proportional to the displacement
but in the
opposite direction.
Let's see what happens
when we work with
the hyperbolic functions.
Suppose now I have a particle
moving along the x-axis.
OK?
And I know this position at any
time, 't', is sinh of 'kt'
where 'k' happens to
be a constant.
What is 'dx/dt'?
The derivative of 'sinh
u' with respect to
'u' is 'cosh u'.
So the derivative of 'sinh kt'
with respect to 't' would be
'cosh kt' times the derivative
of 'kt' with respect to 't',
which is just 'k'.
In other words, the chain
rule again, OK?
Now knowing that 'dx/dt' is
'k cosh kt', ''d 2 x' 'dt
squared'' would be what?
The derivative of 'cosh kt' is
'sinh kt' times the derivative
of 'kt' with respect to 't'.
That gives me another
factor of 'k'.
And therefore the second
derivative of 'x' with respect
to 't' is ''k squared'
sinh kt'.
Now remember what
'sinh kt' is.
We started with the knowledge
that 'sinh kt' is 'x'.
Therefore replacing 'sinh kt'
by what's it's equal to, we
wind up with what?
The second derivative of 'x'
with respect to 't' is equal
to 'k squared x'.
See, no minus sign here.
What happens when we
start with a sinh?
If an object we moved in
according to the rule, 'x'
equals 'sinh kt', its
acceleration would be
proportional to the
displacement
but in the same direction.
You see what that means?
That means the bigger the
displacement, the bigger the
acceleration so the faster
the object keeps moving.
In other words, this thing would
move at a faster and
faster right away from the
origin, et cetera.
That's not our main
concern here.
What is interesting though from
a physical point of view,
and we can use this as a summary
from a physical point
of view, is that the hyperbolic
functions serve as
a solution to the equation ''d
2 x' 'dt squared'' equals 'k
squared x' where 'k'
is a constant.
The circular functions, on the
other hand, solve the equation
''d 2 x' 'dt squared'' is
minus 'k squared x'.
In other words, from this point
of view, notice again,
from a physical point of view
that the difference between
the circular functions and the
hyperbolic functions are again
just the difference in sign.
As I say, this will be
emphasized more in the exercises.
The obvious next lesson, I think
you can see it coming by
this stage in the game, will,
of course, be the inverse
hyperbolic functions.
And we'll see why those are
important next time.
But until then, good bye.
ANNOUNCER 2: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.